Cheryl Burke who is here hanging with us
and last week her partner Ray Lewis had
to drop out of the competition due to an
injury how's ray doing it it's weird
that one of the toughest guys in NFL
history gets hurt
dancing he must have been in a lot of
pain dancing people don't understand
it's a sport this is probably why
there's so many injuries but ray it's
all ready Lewis hit people for a live
like yeah he brought the cage cha-cha on
them I hear you tonight your best friend
Leah Remini is going to be a guest judge
how do you think she'll do I think
Julio's gonna do amazing
I think he's gonna be the People's Voice
she's very honest yes we talk about the
show all the time
did you give her any advice I said
listen just be honest and be you know
nice nice get ready all meanwhile let's
talk about married life oh my god is
married you're married Matthew Lawrence
four months now right
Oh who's counting I mean clearly me Oh
how's it been amazing because I don't
think a lot of my friends that I was
ever gonna get married but uh but I am
I'm happily married and there's a sense
of calmness you know people are just
noticing how happy I am and I just feel
like I'm at peace you know you guys
first dated back in what 2007 oh I had
no friends cuz honestly someone could
have told me that things were a little
too short let's show everybody let's
just go back to the et vault and show
everything wait to it spray tan it's a
new hairstyle something new I've had my
short hair for the last three seasons on
Dancing with the Stars and I thought you
know why not just change it up and have
long hair I loved it it was awesome
yeah it's incredibly real like I don't
like it when you can really really tell
cuz I think it's I don't this is really
cool let's get freaked out accuse our
relationship exciting
my god how embarrassing incredibly
interesting right like that was the
interview about my hair
mmm crazy headlines breaking news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]